[Música]
y hoy se conmemora el día internacional
contra la homofobia la transfobia y la
bifobia una fecha para recordar la lucha
por la igualdad de los derechos de la
comunidad lgbti fue un 17 de mayo de
1990 cuando la Organización Mundial de
la Salud eliminó la homosexualidad de la
lista de enfermedades mentales pero 33
años después la discriminación por
orientación sexual aún persiste en
muchas partes del mundo por ejemplo en
América Latina Venezuela Cuba Honduras y
El Salvador siguen quedándose cortos en
el respeto por los derechos de la
población trans para hablar de este tema
saludamos en la capital salvadoreña a
Mónica Hernández ahí es directora de la
organización aspid El Salvador señor
Hernández bienvenida directo a América
gracias Buenos días a todos
los televidentes un gusto Mi nombre es
Mónica Linares Hernández soy una
activista trans de El Salvador una
activista que nos mantenemos en pie de
lucha por los Derechos Humanos de las
poblaciones lgbti y las poblaciones
trans en específico y como bien lo decía
hoy diecisiete de Mayo es una fecha
importante para nosotras poder seguir
con esta lucha en la reivindicación de
los Derechos Humanos de las personas
trans Hernández quiero empezar
preguntándole por los desafíos y los
obstáculos que persisten en estos países
que acabamos de mencionar en la lucha
por la igualdad y los derechos de la
comunidad trans que tienen en común
estas naciones por ejemplo
Yo creo que el primer punto que tienen
en común Es
la falta de voluntad política los
estados para poder
generar políticas públicas inclusivas
una ley de identidad de género la cual
ya la misma
cidh la Corte Interamericana ha mandado
a estos países a que firmen los tratados
internacionales y a que garanticen una
ley de identidad de género en el caso de
Honduras por ejemplo el caso de Vicky
Hernández
dio paso para que exista una ley de
identidad de género en El Salvador de
hecho hemos tenido hasta una visita en
loco de la cidh donde manda al Estado
salvadoreño legislar a favor de las
personas trans de los Derechos Humanos
de las personas trans de un de un
derecho al nombre de la ley de identidad
y de hecho hasta la sala del
constitucional de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia ha mandado a la asamblea
legislativa que pueda legislar a favor
de las personas trans de hecho este año
se cumplió un año
que la asamblea debía legislar a favor
de los Derechos Humanos de las personas
trans Y tenemos hasta ahorita una
asamblea que está en desacato por no
cumplir un mandato de la sala una sala
que fue impuesta por por estos diputados
ahora Cuál es la situación de las
personas trans en el ámbito laboral por
ejemplo que nos puedes decir al respecto
creo que es uno de los países con menos
eh tasa de población trans en una en un
trabajo en un empleo formal que no sea
salones de belleza el trabajo sexual que
no sea el comercio informal Porque no
tenemos políticas inclusivas y el
Ministerio de trabajo no garantiza que
las personas trans puedan acceder a un
empleo digno dentro de dentro de
cualquier empresa del estado o cualquier
cualquier institución del estado o
empresas privadas
señor Hernández ustedes están llevando a
cabo una campaña actualmente que se
llama simplemente quiero vivir como tú
de dónde sale este nombre En qué se
inspira para hacer
yo creo que nuestro mayor punto de
encuentro entre cuatro países
Venezuela El Salvador Honduras ha sido
esa necesidad esa falencia de de
Derechos Humanos que existen en estos
países y en la región de Centroamérica
por ejemplo
no existen garantías jurídicas Para
nuestras poblaciones y específicamente
para las personas trans hombres y
mujeres trans no existe
ninguna ley que garantice que podamos
vivir como vive todo el mundo en general
es decir tenemos falta de derechos
tenemos esa negación del acceso al
derecho al nombre principalmente y esto
nos lleva a tener falencia en cuanto al
acceso a otros derechos humanos que son
mínimos para todas las poblaciones el
trabajo el el derecho al trabajo el
derecho a una educación el derecho a una
vivienda digna sabemos que antes
teníamos una expectativa de vida de las
personas trans de 35 años de edad ahora
hemos visto que también habemos personas
trans adultas mayores y que estas
estamos en en una deficiencia de
Derechos Humanos en una calidad de vida
que no es
no es digna para una persona lgbt mucho
menos para una persona para una persona
adulta mayor trans que tiene que
terminar siendo cuidadora de otra
persona adulta mayor señora Hernández
desde su perspectiva Cómo cree que ha
evolucionado la opinión pública y la
actitud de la sociedad frente a la
población lgbti en América Latina
creo que es más la apertura que existe
de la población en general pero seguimos
en el mismo sentir que es el estado
salvadoreño quien no tiene la voluntad
política que pueda garantizar que las
personas trans vivamos sin
discriminación por orientación sexual
identidad y expresión de género es decir
las personas trans Seguimos estando en
un vacío
existencial porque para para la
población en general no existimos Porque
no tenemos un documento que sea acorde a
nuestra identidad y expresión de género
hoy precisamente tenemos un par de
actividades donde queremos hacer presión
a la asamblea legislativa para que pueda
legislar a favor de una ley de identidad
de género que la sala de lo
constitucional de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia Ya le mandó y es algo que debe
cumplir la asamblea legislativa pero que
ha entrado en desacato a partir de
de ya de un tiempo porque tenemos hasta
el día de hoy
84 días de de retraso con el
cumplimiento de y la y la asamblea
legislativa ni siquiera se ha
pronunciado en decir necesitamos tiempo
estamos legislando vamos a a discutir
esa ley de identidad que existe que ya
está dentro de la asamblea pero que está
archivada bueno ya para finalizar señor
Hernández a su juicio qué estrategias
deben implementarse para promover la
aceptación y la inclusión de la
comunidad trans específicamente
yo creo que lo primero es generar una
voluntad política por parte de los
tomadores de decisión definitivamente
estamos en un momento que es el momento
para toda latinoamérica y que puede
existir una ley de identidad de género
para estos países que una ley de
identidad de género no viene a dañar a
terceros sino más bien a poder acceder a
los a los servicios públicos a los
Derechos Humanos básicos para las
poblaciones lgbti Y definitivamente
necesitamos un estado comprometido un
estado Que cumpla
lo que ha firmado ante los en los
tratados internacionales y que cumpla
con la sentencia que la sala le ha
dictado para que pueda generar una ley
de identidad de género que garantice los
Derechos Humanos para las personas trans
Mónica Hernández directora de la
organización aspira en El Salvador
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos hoy que
cuando se conmemora el día internacional
contra la homofobia y la trans fobia y
la bifobia
gracias Y ustedes televidentes también
gracias por sintonizarnos no se
desconecten qué minutos regresamos con
más noticias esto es directo América
[Música]